immer mehr corona fälle in großstädten
auch stuttgart in mainz und essen haben
den kritischen wert überschritten
nrw verschärft die regeln neue proteste
in belarus die polizei geht hart gegen
demonstranten vor
machthaber lukaschenko trifft
oppositionelle im gefängnis
unschlagbar in paris rafael nadal
gewinnt gegen die nummer eins der welt
und zum dreizehnten mal die french open
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen zum nachrichtenüberblick am
sonntag norbert könig ist auch hier mit
dem sport in etwa acht minuten genommen
immer mehr städte werden zur krone
hotspots und damit nehmen auch die
einschränkungen weiter zu sperrstunden
werden vorverlegt das trinken auf
öffentlichen plätzen reglementiert die
gästezahl bei feiern reduziert
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
mahnen an die regeln einzuhalten
die lage sei ernst auch in mainz
stuttgart und essen wurde jetzt die
warnstufe von 50 neuinfektionen pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen
überschritten
zuvor waren es schon berlin frankfurt
bremen und köln in nordrhein westfalen
werden die regeln jetzt verschärft an
seinem stern berichtet die virus hotspot
liste sie wird länger essen nordrhein
westfalen das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland die regierung hatte
krisensitzung ergebnis mehr einheitliche
regeln
generell dürfen nur noch maximal 50
menschen an einer privaten feier etwa im
restaurant teilnehmen so der
ministerpräsident und es gibt harte
vorschriften für alle nrw risikogebiete
die zahl der personen aus verschiedenen
haushalten die im öffentlichen raum
kontakt haben dürfen wird von zehn auf
fünf reduziert die öffnungszeiten von
kneipen und restaurants werden dann
eingeschränkt veranstaltungen über 500
teilnehmer draußen und 250 in
innenräumen werden generell abgesagt und
es gilt mund nasenschutz pflicht auf
vielen plätzen maskiert in die stadt
bald auch in stuttgart die metropole ist
nun ebenfalls corona problemzone ab
mittwoch gilt in der innenstadt neben
der masken pflicht auch ein
alkoholverbot draußen ab 23 uhr feiern
nur noch im kleinen kreis finde ich in
ordnung wenn man damit corona in griff
bekommt
also die die person selber feiern das
könnt ihr euch noch sinnvoll sein aber
masken und alkohol abends läuft hier
nicht umstritten aber nötig so die stadt
die jetzt auch die bundeswehr offiziell
um hilfe bittet die soll die
gesundheitsämter unterstützen bei der
nachverfolgung von corona
kontaktpersonen
jetzt geht es damit wir schulen kitas
und wirtschaft nicht herunterfahren
müssen und nicht in verhältnisse geraten
gewisse in frankreich und spanien leider
leider haben davon ist deutschland
aktuell weit entfernt aber in vielen
landkreisen und vor allem in den
ballungszentren ist das virus eben
wieder auf dem vormarsch
ja und mit der kalten jahreszeit steigen
nicht nur die kogit 19 zahlen auch die
grippewelle geht bald los wie sich die
viren und krankheiten unterscheiden
können sie sich online in einer
interaktiven 3d story ansehen in der
zdf- heute- app noch vor einer woche war
er im krankenhaus als wohl bekanntester
corona patient der welt er zeigte
symptome erhielt starke medikamente und
nun will donald trump wieder unter
menschen gehen und auf wahlkampftour
trotz kritik von medizinern gestern
schon zeigte sich der us präsident
öffentlich und angriffslustig wird der
sonne wald präsidentschafts startet im
wahlkampf wieder durch neun tage nach
bekanntwerden seiner crew wird
erkrankung tritt er erstmals wieder vor
seine anhänger
vom balkon des weißen hauses verkündet
er dass es ihm wieder prächtig gehe
den demokraten um so beiden wirft ein
sozialistisches und kommunistisches
programm vor mit dem sie das land in
eine krise stürzen werden ihre politik
bringt nur unglück armut und ärger der
schläfrige joe hat schwarze und latinos
betrogen wenn ihr glaubt er könne das
land regieren dann täuscht ihr euch joe
biden ist derweil auf wahlkampftour im
schlüsselstaat pennsylvania statt trumps
öffentlichen auftritt zu kritisieren
erklärt er wie er die wirtschaft wieder
ankurbeln will
immer wenn das wort klimawandel auf
kommt denkt donald trump das sei ein
scherz ich denke dabei an jobs die
gelder die wir einnehmen werden werden
wir in arbeitende menschen in west
ab morgen wird donald trump wieder auf
wahlkampf tour gehen in die heiß
umkämpfte staaten florida pennsylvania
und mediziner kritisieren diesen schritt
ins weiße haus dürfte momentan überhaupt
keine veranstaltungen abhalten dutzende
mitarbeiter sind infiziert wenn das ein
unternehmen oder eine schule wäre würde
man es schließen
das hält donald trump und sein team
nicht auf dreieinhalb wochen vor der
wahl hat der präsident die aufholjagd
begonnen in landesweiten umfragen liegt
er nach wie vor hinter joe biden
trotz milliarden investitionen fehlen in
deutschland immer mehr kita plätze für
kinder unter drei jahren
das geht aus berechnungen des instituts
der deutschen wirtschaft hervor
demnach fehlten zum stichtag im märz
rund 342.000 öffentlich geförderte
betreuungsplätze die lücke habe sich im
vergleich zum jahr 2015 fast verdoppelt
grund seien veränderte betreuungs
wünsche der eltern und gestiegenen
kinderzahlen aus belarus erreichen uns
nachrichten die nicht leicht einzuordnen
sind
so hat sich machthaber lukaschenko
gestern vier stunden mit oppositionellen
getroffen allerdings im gefängnis wo sie
wegen ihrer kritik an der wohl
gefälschten wahl in haft sitzen
oppositionsführerin of ska sagte einen
dialog führe man nicht in der
gefängniszelle
auch deshalb ging heute wieder
zehntausende auf die straße
für becker die proteste hatten kaum
begonnen da stürzten sich uniformierte
bereits auf die teilnehmer früher
festnahmen früher einsatz von
wasserwerfern
um die menschen zu stoppen die in
belarus friedlich demonstrierten
wir fordern dass die politischen
gefangenen freigelassen werden wir
wollen neuwahlen und dass jeder der
gefoltert hat bestraft wird
seit den umstrittenen
präsidentschaftswahlen versucht die
opposition machthaber lukaschenko zum
dialog zu bewegen
gestern das erste gespräch unter
lukaschenko bedingungen im gefängnis
einige seiner politischen gegner sind
seit dem wahlkampf andere seit dem
aufflammen der proteste inhaftiert die
hälfte von irgendwie sind juristen und
sie wissen ganz genau eine verfassung
wird nicht auf der straße geschrieben
ich versuche nicht nur ihre anhänger
sondern die gesamte gesellschaft zu
überzeugen dass man die probleme weiter
gefasst betrachten muss die demokratie
bewegung zeigt sich heute unbeeindruckt
von lukaschenkos auftritt konnte will
sich als guter zu präsentieren damit die
alten leute vom fernseher denken er sei
bereit für gespräche mit der opposition
wie ein terrorist der mit seinen geiseln
spricht und er verkauft es den leuten
noch als verhandlungen im strömenden
regen fiel der protestmarsch heute etwas
kleiner aus als in den wochen zuvor
wieder gestiegen hingegen die brutalität
der einsatzkräfte blendgranaten flogen
demonstrierende wurden verletzt
wieder ist bei einem mutmasslichen
autorennen ein unbeteiligter autofahrer
getötet worden
augenzeugen zufolge hatten sich drei
sportwagen einen rennen auf der a 66 in
richtung frankfurt geliefert einer der
wagen schleuderte gegen die
mittelleitplanke und kollidierte mit
einem unbeteiligten auto der fahrer
darin starb die polizei nahm einen 29
und einen 26 jährigen fest nach dem
dritten sportwagenfahrer wird noch
gefahndet
ja und wir sind beim sport und einem
bemerkenswerten tennis-finale french
open aber mit einem herrscher auf sand
aus spanien
zum dreizehnten mal gewinnt rafael nadal
die french open glatt in drei sätzen
gegen den weltranglisten erster novak
djokovic seine neue matchbilanz im stade
roland garros 100 zu zwei siege
unvergleichlich dreizehnter titel in 13
finale von roland garros rafael nadal
ist der könig von paris in einem
größtenteils einseitigen finale gegen
novak djokovic der spanier unten immer
mit den besseren mitteln djokovic
versucht alles bringt nadal ins laufen
vergebens die beiden ersten sätze gehen
an nadal
hoffnung und ausgeglichenes spiel erst
in satz drei aber nach zwei stunden 41
ist alles vorbei nadal in perfektion auf
dem roten sand von paris ist der 20
major titel seiner karriere
auf den deutschland achter ist verlass
das großboot holt für den deutschen
ruderverband den einzigen titel bei den
europameisterschaften dem einzigen
international bedeutenden wettkampf des
jahres auf dem malta see im polnischen
poznan zeigte der deutschland-achter
dabei erneut seine große dominanz
technisch hervorragend rudernd dazu mit
der nötigen harmonie im boot ließ die
mannschaft von bundestrainer uwe bender
dabei der internationalen konkurrenz
keine chance und gewann den achten titel
bei europameisterschaften
drei weitere silbermedaillen an diesem
finaltag rundeten das gute ergebnis der
deutschen mannschaft ab überraschend
silber dekoriert dabei auch der frauen
achter des deutschen ruderverbandes
formel-1-weltmeister lewis hamilton
gewinnt vor max verstappen und danny
ricardo den großen preis der eifel auf
dem nürburgring für den briten ist es
der 91 grand prix sieg der karriere
damit stellt er den rekord von michael
schumacher ein
sebastian vettel wird nach einem
ausrutscher elfter nico hülkenberg
immerhin achter besondere ehrenpreis für
hamilton ein helm von michael schumacher
aus den händen seines sohnes mit schöne
gäste absolut dank genau wird bleibt
noch das wetter im nordwesten und im
süden zeitweise regen sonst teils wolkig
teils sonnig bei fünf grad an den alpen
und 14 grad am niederrhein
so viel von uns für den moment danke für
ihr interesse
marietta slomka meldet sich mit dem
heute journal um drei viertel 10
und wir sind morgen wieder für sie da
punkt 19 uhr
jetzt aber erwartet sika banerjee mit
berlin direkt